[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's no better than swim so I'm fine
nothing is happening
Oh huh will not really on your only care
because I hear eyes oh do you do
anything do you come towards me in any
way you just stay there like you're
doing [ __ ] nothing in this house oh
let's play the game
stop talking the story iris I used to
work in a company called iris they were
an advertising company
[Music]
oh damn it oh my god did I didn't looks
like you well that's just brilliant
isn't it what do we do now bendy
should I get to work oh that's a machine
wait well it's been boarded up
that's a me little wiles like machine
[Music]
[Applause]
wasting every to hit the light on I
wanna see still it
[Music]
[Applause]
did I just do that wrong I was not
supposed to lose my hand was I I did I
just game over
today was I actually supposed to lose my
hand was that actually part of the game
oh my God look at it eating over
everything oh I love this game so far
save me what do you think that I'm his
entity
[Applause]
okay oh okay so I'm going back to where
I was all that's not - I thought she
locked me in I wonder if there's a story
behind this hoarding okay fine I'm yours
take me what oh she just turns up
everywhere this is long I wanted to quit
I don't want to play this anymore
I want to quit quit I'm sorry I'm sorry
sorry about the screaming I hate hiding
though she comes so close to you Oh